you know i was in duluth for the first
time
last year and i walked i walked up to
the bob dylan
house because there's a house that dylan
was born in he's got a childhood home
and um and i'm outside the house and
this woman comes out on the porch and
she's like
bob dylan and i'm like yeah she's like
you want to see the house and i'm like
sure so she takes me and takes me into
bob dylan's
house and uh there's a husband sitting
in a kitchen table reading a magazine
and he sees me he's like bob dylan and
i'm like yeah he's like yeah
go upstairs and like it's just a real
insane
thing that it's wonderful it was so cool
and then the woman was like you know
about the armory show right and i was
like
no idea and i guess the last show buddy
holly played before he died
bob was at this armory in duluth bob
dylan went as a teenager and was in the
front row
and there's a photo that i saw while i
was in duluth of bob dylan in the front
row looking at buddy holly which is like
so so creepy and and crazy and weird
that is great well i look the one thing
i love one of many things i love about
duluth
is that uh it is ridiculously easy to
get in touch with anybody like my
husband likes this um
band called low and they're from duluth
um
and uh we just facebook you know
messaged them and they said want to get
lunch today
like it's not like you know ellie in new
york it's like uh
can we reschedule it in 2022.
um right i got a window was it like what
is it like alan
it's like alan sparhawk in them ellen
spurhock
his wife mimi we've been to their house
now
that's wild that's insane so it's just
like now it's not like l.a like we
should do we should we have to hang out
and then you'll see them in two years
this is like
no they're like no we're you're coming
over
right yeah no it's really uh yeah a huge
fan of you guys
do you want to live together okay
that's what you did that's exactly what
she did to me though moses i was like
hey
we've got extra space i've always wanted
to have kids in theory
so i figure if somebody's in their 30s
it's like uh i can handle it for
three to four weeks i'll make you eggs
comics are so charitable sometimes it's
like
insane like the amount of comedians who
like
who have hosted me in like various
countries and cities
like elaine boozler i did like one show
with elaine boozler
and she's like stay at my place when i'm
at like and it's a real like
it's a real community that's what i miss
so much about this like i ran into
i ran into chris fleming on the street a
couple of weeks ago and i wanted to like
grab his leg and never let go
like i just miss running into people i
miss the whole
yeah but not scheduling people but like
like accidentally seeing people
is is a great way to do it what would it
take for anyone to
perform again like what kind of
restrictions what kind of death rate is
anyone thinking about that or they're
just
moving on a new president the the
that there's some sort of cure that that
would be good because i just wouldn't
want to
do a club and then somebody get ill
yeah my watch right that's my that's my
biggest fear is like i just get an email
it's just like
great show my grandma died yeah
yes what a what a unload to put on you
yeah and it's your big story about your
mom is [ __ ] worth it i gotta say
it's not that good i'm over there in
maria where it's just like i don't know
man i feel like there's been times in
history where we had to take a break
yeah and this might just be like yeah
everybody take a break everybody i mean
i
understand you know he was promised
something that god took from him
but uh that's how i frame it in my head
and by god i mean deadline
[Laughter]
yeah but you're fine jack to be like i'm
just gonna focus on other things and be
a human being i'm not fine with it
i'm i'm i would way rather see you guys
all the time and do stand up and be
drunk till 3am at the store or whatever
but you know it is what it is and if you
don't react and
you know change some [ __ ] you gonna just
be a sad sack of the crib
performing in that weird liminal four or
five day
gray space between when the world was
normal when the world was shut down it's
crazy
i feel comfortable saying this but i
said to my i was on tour i was like
legit on a tour of the uk that had a
couple weeks left and
and they said to my agent like hey i
think i should cancel the shows
because cat coming to cancel their shows
and gone home and i called her and i was
like is there going to be a problem and
she wrote
bro yeah and so
my agents were like why what's the big
deal like
it's not a problem and i was like yeah
and then my dad is my dad is in charge
of distributing ppe now for the
hospitals and universities in
massachusetts and he called me he's like
hey uh you know i never tell you what to
do but maybe you should look into
cancelling your shows
and so i called the agents back and i
was like i want to cancel the shows and
they're like you are
so alarmist but like we will deal with
this sort of like
jewish neuroses and this is my uk
these are my uk agents and they're like
we
we shut it down but i did one last show
in glasgow
and and that night had like a real like
last dance on the titanic feel to it it
was like a real
i was like welcome to the last show
we're gonna go to for five months
and people really it had a special
sad feeling to it that i'll never be
able to forget and those agents by the
way like their whole company shut down
like that
that they don't one of them's like
working as a carpenter now my goodness
that's such a far
fall that seems like a ridiculous far
from grace like
everybody everybody at quibby already
has a new job
how bad you'd be like hope it's not real
because then you have to do construction
yeah bro they call that the reverse
jesus where you go from an elevated
position
back to carpentry and see so now he
doesn't send you scripts he just sends
you
tape measures he generally was like hey
i'm working on this table
and like that's the kind of thing he's
like working on this table do you want
to be involved we got a good perfect no
but like
i got left attached legs are attached uh
we're circling some stain we're looking
at
hogany moses does spend lots of time on
deadline that his
that uh that's the uh just keep
refreshing keep refreshing every moment
you got something
who's doing what is anyone doing better
than me it must be a hell of a work at
deadline if you have any showbiz
aspirations that every day you just get
100 notices of people who are like
who have something fun to announce
deadline is just the school
announcements of the entertainment
business
well it's just a dude comes i'm just
like uh
in the morning we'll have a new show
with jason bateman and newcomer
right but the the one is when someone
gets recast
at the table read when they that makes
you feel better about your entire life
and the fact that you hit someone with
your car in 2013. it's like well they
showed up
they were who they are and they weren't
good enough oh my god
i don't think i can up that you know
your story is more beautiful but my last
performance was at the the newsstand in
that
lower room yeah awesome super [ __ ]
awesome room
love those people over there love the
guys and i was
on a scout with my buddy richie keane
for a show that me and my friends were
getting ready to make
and because of covert it all just shut
down you know life is fine move on but
it was like
we're making the tv show we were
scouting moses knows all this
we're making a tv show we're scouting we
were look we were
like getting all the shots down we fully
went through our list we got everybody
ready to go
the monday when like the whole when tom
tom hanks got it the day we shut
everything down
and uh trump said he's gonna shut down
all flights and so
uh viacom had to give me an earlier
flight had to put me on a flight back to
la so i wouldn't be trapped in new york
i get to
i get there and everybody from the uk
is just standing in a group because they
wouldn't let them fly home
yeah and so it was just really like
scary like
everybody was being incredibly rude to
asian people like i was watching the
xenophobia happening in front of my eyes
like it was
it was crazy and then there was just
like a group of some biscuity
[ __ ] just standing off to the
side
with nowhere to go your prayer has
changed
i luckily got on the plane flew over we
were like ah you know this is just like
people going crazy
nope literally the last show i did was
at the stand
hanging out with like i think it was
like who was there that night
like clayton english was with me for
some reason it was it was just a great
night
and then the whole world shut down even
live stand up now in moses i'm sure your
experience is different and i'm i'm
about to like i'm going to do some clubs
at the end of the year but like
i did a show where the stage was the
back of a pickup truck
and i looked out and i was just like
what kind of world are we living in
we're just like live from the
thunderdome
we're just like is every show has like a
genuine
post-apocalyptic feel to it i'm with
jack a bit on zoom shows like
i i do them now because i can't live
without some kind of stand-up
but it feels very much like i bombed a
couple weeks ago
two feet from my bed like
that's hard you can't leave the venue
yeah like if i
really want to look at a place i truly
bond i have to go to like sunnyvale
california and remember 2013 now it's
just like oh yeah i remember three
months ago where on my couch i
bombed like where a guy kept playing
video games with his sister
while i was on stage oh that's great
they're completely tuned out
yeah just completely that's that's
better than not levy it's just like i
it's on your a tab that's the other
thing there's no like
audience accountability people like when
if they heckle it's like that
[ __ ] wisconsin what you really
gonna do
yeah you're gonna come back it'll just
turn off his camera you can't crush a
heckler who lives
in a like a different state so everyone
uh can stay on except maria you have
three seconds to
say who you are i'm so sorry
uh yeah we are out of time but this is
honestly so much fun
that um you know i was out in a very
real way having a rough morning for
whatever reason
and uh this made me feel better so thank
you for for uh
coming on this with me it's just nice to
see everybody coming out it's good to
see people's faces does anyone have
anything
uh coming up that they want to uh get
the message out
about i know jack has uh doomsday
mixtape which is the podcast i was
talking about which
i highly highly recommend don't fall
asleep to it it's
hilarious so good i think big mom's
coming out at some point some other news
will probably come out when
white people allow me to say it i'm
giving you permission
guess what um i've got an album out
i just put out an album because i was
like i need somehow to
still be putting out stand-up but i put
out an album called until now which i
recorded at acme maria
minneapolis i love acne i love it
and also um i've been phone banking
for the abiding campaign a lot and if
people have a spare time now
you should phone bank it's super easy
and apparently it really helps so like
now it sounds so dumb but like i don't
know
be really nice to have a new president
in a couple of weeks so
so maybe just don't ruin my birthday is
that your birthday
my birth my birthday is the sixth so
whatever happens on the third
i know the voting is probably gonna take
one to two weeks to actually get
everything together and i know they're
gonna try and destroy the election we
can talk about this another day
but just like let me at least if you're
gonna if you're
either blow by now the water and we're
like we live in a terrible place
don't make it some weird contention that
my birthday is awkward
yeah right everyone needs to phone bank
we're
not doing any yeah either biden blows
him out or trump blows him out but i
need my day
you need your day it's important too
that's very scorpio that's very scorpio
thank you you have anything
coming up that people should check out i
have a free audible book that you can
get on uh
audible um called you are a comedy
special
um it's about two hours long and it's a
15 step guide
how to write your own uh one hour comedy
four how to force yourself force
yourself first yourself right a full
hour of comedy
uh because uh that's what i have to do
um it doesn't come naturally anyway so
that's the only thing i have to plug
great so you're selling two vibrators in
case anybody is curious
well i have to say bills have been saged
and put in a local trash for duluth
minnesota
illegal to sell things that have been
saged um that's our show this is
this is uh so fun i'm very proud thank
you moses
yeah thank you very much to see you guys
so nice to see you maria bamford alex
edelman and jack knight
uh thank you and hang in there hope you
have a great week